hello reject nation it's Greg Alva here
John Nicolas Cage is back people Nikolas
would he ever go away I don't think so
no he's just been on DVD he never goes
away just depends on which level of
distro he's at today is this movie
called mom and dad I think it's a horror
film I bet it is
laughing can be called mom and dad and
have a good prognosis those characters
disturbing horror violence language
throughout some sexual Union teenage
drug use
totes abhorrence I hope the trailer
stays in this town
[Music]
[Music]
that's the opposite of cooties
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so I want to see it I want to see this
yeah put a fork in me let's go like
really bad right yeah the most bowled
over I've been by a trailer in a long
time like that trailer grabbed me by the
testes and just kept Nicolas Cage got
hit in the head with a soccer ball to
turn around I was like wait a minute
it's gonna be perfect you honor from
Nicolas Cage to go frigging bananas in
man yeah one for selma blair Tuesday
well since I've seen her and she looks
like she's on the right pitch with this
too and yeah like if there's one thing I
appreciate about Nicolas Cage because
it's easier to roll your eyes and laugh
and be confused by Nicolas Cage but I
really appreciate when he just puts his
all into some lattice and I like the way
how when they're they're kind of going
into whatever parent does zombie attack
mode they're they're in with the kind of
crazy and held shutter speed yeah gee
[ __ ] crank yeah crank yes ghost riders I
don't know who made this morning I feel
like this year we've got in several new
I saw tragedy girls this year there's
another Christmas one with the kids on
the horror movies with killer kids out
there now suburbia and in family
scenario yeah it's refreshing to see a
twist on it where the parent of the
parents have all gone crazy because
everyone's made the jokes about parents
when you kill their kids yeah and now
it's like this disease that's reading
and the Bears are getting like demented
and trying to kill their children so
same there's disturbing horror violence
in here which I'm sure will be like a
little whimsical like disturbing what
whimsical kind of like how tragic yeah
I'm wondering how how much you're gonna
commit to the kids dying in that movie
though cuz this really did give me like
a reverse cooties vibe yeah definitely
more
Ayaka tatum more like isn't that guy
Brian Taylor ranked yeah he's the
perfect director for something like this
though he is he's the perfect director
well this is the perfect the mania the
manic miss behind it
yeah this is the perfect level like this
looks like you know a lean mean
thrilling probably really twisted horror
movie yeah I want to see it I do too and
it looks like it'll be crazy kinetic
shot in the right spots I feel like
where these guy can get carried away
like when I saw a gamer or even part of
it some people prefer crank to high
voltage over the first one but that's a
little bit too much of like the
craziness kinetic Ness for me
same thing with Ghost Rider too like a
little too much of that based off the
trailer it seems like there are scenes
where it's shot normally shot like a
regular scene and probably takes its
time then when they're going all monster
is when it goes all the kinetic crazy
solid is these directors are known for
doing yeah so I'm hoping he has a good
balance of knowing went to edit and
shoot the film to make it or break it
but at least from this trailer does look
like and then you know wow I was I was
delightfully surprised I thought we were
gonna watch it sure that was gonna bag
on that was I'm delightfully surprised
trailer yeah it's nice to see a grim
grinning like black horror comedy or
something like that was what do you
think of the mom and dad trailer hit for
Nicolas Cage today so you can subscribe
to the real rejects click that
notification bell download and follow us
on the Stardust app first people follow
us before Tyrone before the flick pick
before Wendy Lee for epic voice guy
Horsch Mo's I was bored Shaun's before
us first please please just do it for us